okay so this was about hyper parameter
search okay but now there is an
underlying question also as well on how
our model are behaving we know that they
are brittle and spurious so let's just
see a little bit what this means
brittles mean what if we change a little
bit the input we can see weird behavior
like this was very very visible on the
geunyoung paper on squad they show that
if you add like a random sentence at the
end of the squad context like the answer
that the model predict for the question
are totally different the model is just
lost because we've moved this very small
modification with lis we've left two
training domain okay but our models are
also spurious spurious mean that say we
really do the least amount of work to
get the bear from best performances so
if they are easy heuristics that they
can leverage for instance like we've
talked about lexical overlap when you
have a lot of overlap on the two
sentences of an ally of M and Li like
the model will very quickly learn that
lot of overlap means that the right
classification should be an tenant but
this is not what we would like who like
a model to go to the semantic meaning of
the sentence and not just to stay on the
surface from just to stay on the lexical
overlap heuristics so this is called
spurious and it's also mean amidala are
very fragile because in both this case
when we leave a little bit the training
data set the model gives wrong
prediction and fail in unexpected ways
so how can we solve that that way as
well well one way would be first to get
better ideas of how they behave and I
think here linguistics is very important
there is this nice talk by le public why
we should care about linguistics well I
think it's really the time for
linguistic to to become to come back to
NLP and to replace some some of the
machine learning approach and to help
design better evaluation okay because we
know that these linguistics rules
they're kind of the underlying rules we
would like our models to learn so they
are probably good not-not-not to try to
be a training that said to the
very good to build evaluation at a
certain failure evaluation that's it
okay now what we really want to do is to
try to provide good inductive biases
which means that our models will want to
learn these rules there will be it will
be easier for a model to learn these
rules than to learn these heuristics
which is called an inductive biases that
will that means the model goes toward
the solution that we want faster than
toward a solution that we don't want so
one idea is all the work on
compositionality that we show we know
that composition IT is important for
model to get the good the good
understanding of the meaning of a
sentence so if we can deal models that
are good on compositionality that would
be one way to incorporate some
linguistics so this is one possibility
so how could how can we do that well we
can trick the architecture of the model
this model they have this attention
heads so we can try to encode in these
attention heads some of this graph that
we see in linguistics like dependency
graft or like shallow like a Sarah
relation and this was the nice word for
instance from another a masked rebel the
Lisa linguistically informed self
attention for semantic role labeling
that was the best paper Ottoman LP two
years ago I think where some of the
attention head were actually trained
with additionally augmented data with
semantic role labeling okay and the
model reached better performances
because it was able to interpret this
this inductive biases there is a lot of
nice work as well graph computer
convolutional network phrase so this
work by by Diego on us by Sting and even
Tita
where they explore the semantics in
translation with graph neural network
encoding the the dependency trees okay
so you can try 240 architecture another
a different way is to try to add this
inductive bias in the training data here
is one funny example it's an anonymous
paper on an open review I think it's
very nice they try to help birds by
providing after a training sample for
birds like a form of
semantic role labeling so they will say
okay this word is like a predicate this
work is the first argument okay they add
this this semantic role labeling
information after the training so this
form like just the input for the model
and then at test time you just don't
really you just don't use this you just
don't you don't input Montee data and
you see that the model actually gets
improved whoa business by being trained
with this information okay they
experimented on an adversarial squad
that's cool swag that is it okay so now
probably what we want to do for that is
that we probably want to work on
pre-training to get some deeper
linguistic information in our pre
training that set as well like for
instance we can add more like
linguistically informs panel level
representation we can try to have like
more modular ready to put on our models
and this is all very open but how can we
incorporate this the linguistic
information in pre training will be
probably important as well an
alternative way to make this model
robust is to add common sense because
usually they are lacking some linguistic
stuff but as well as common sense there
are some limits so why do we need common
sense because we can't learn everything
from text let's have a look you know
that for instance sheeps are white okay
but in text usually we don't say that
because it's too obvious
and on the contrary we often talk about
black sheeps because yeah because that's
a common expression okay so when you ask
a model that was trained on text only
when you ask it what color is either
sheep it will say oh I'm not sure it's
probably black okay because it has no
way to know that white is the real
answer okay this is called the reporting
bias it means that in text we usually
don't state the obvious we don't waive
common sense so how can we help the
mother learn that well there are various
way we can try to add like a knowledge
base in the knowledge base we like have
this sheep node and we connect it with
color white nodes so the model can learn
that this is the color of a normal field
we can add multi model when you show a
picture to the model with a white sheep
and the model can just look at it and
say oh yeah okay it's white I can see it
on the picture and then the last part is
maybe you can just tell the model we can
have like human-in-the-loop training
like humans are actually learning the
model can ask what color is the sheep on
the new human or some somebody say yeah
it's white and on the model nose it's so
this is human-in-the-loop training is
that all the way but you can see that
all of them involve something other than
texts we need something like more
structure like database or we need like
picture we need another modality for
model to be able to learn common sense
so yeah ensuring has been as been
working a lot of common sense just done
really really great stuff the first
question is bodies common sense what is
common sense it's basic level of
practical knowledge in everyday service
situation there is a very blurry blurry
front here with bias okay because some
Tower of this common sense is exactly
bias that we don't want in our model but
some part is just normal thing like here
it's okay to keep the closet door open
but it's not okay to keep the fridge
door open because the food doesn't want
to go
Wow okay so the way they did that the
way they tackle that is to build a lot
of that sets they'll be there like a lot
of that sets that try to gather some
common sense and I really want to
highlight some of them vino grande is
really fascinating when it's an
extension now the winogradsky my
challenge is solved okay we've started
with that later on earlier and now they
build a successor to it which is a vino
grande they have all this common sense
cosmos cue a lot of visual common sense
that said they're all very interesting
and let me just show you maybe if you
want to be just repaper
you should recall the atomic comets and
the vinegar and a paper atomic is this
relation database that I was talking
about okay that encode comments and set
across the
Komets is a nice paper by antoine
busloads is about using transformers pre
transformer to actually mount this
knowledge graph and we know ground is
the successor to vinegar schema so let
me show you just a little bit about vino
grande okay because that's interesting
we are building all these data sets from
Krauss whose information and actually
it's very hard to be a nice crowd
crowdsourcing set up and I think they
are a lot of experience on this topic
which is very interesting so here we
know grande the main problem is that we
don't want people first we want people
to have ideas and not to generate from
just the simplest the simplest IDs they
have so they use some way to enhance the
creativity with what they call random
unco words so the people in the crowd
sauce the Turkish they will have this
random word that they are supposed to
use in their example the example they
are writing and this helps a lot to make
them like creatively create new examples
and they also use like very strong data
validation set up where they fine-tune
state-of-the-art models on the data and
I try to remove that that's too easy to
predict okay so this could be like like
an online data creation process where
each time you have a better
state-of-the-art model you actually
through new examples okay to remove them
and they show that the state-of-the-art
model from now they are like very bad
performances on this well pretty bad
anyway you would need actually a lot of
samples to get to human performances so
that's probably the way forward in
creating crowdsource data set like
trying to make more diversity and try to
filter this data set better okay and
this lead us to the same idea for models
okay the data set should now be evolving
there should be dynamically updated as
new models came here or come in and the
models are actually the same problem
which is called the continual learning
question what is it so that's the end of
the that's the end of our description is
me that bird was trained on like 2018
data it will
always think that the president of like
the United said was the 2018 president
okay but maybe this will change in the
future maybe the president maybe the
like the countries will change and the
model we just never learn this okay and
how do we overcome that well we need
models that are able to evolve over time
okay but then there's the main problem
with this approach there are a lot of
people have been working continual
learning the main problem is called
catastrophic forgetting which means that
you want to learn new stuff without
forgetting everything that you've
learned before and here you have
different approach to try to tackle this
from memory to regularization to
dynamically growing models and this is
probably the way like NLP should go
forward to have these models that are
able to adapt and allowable to
generalize to other domain as well okay
so that's the end for today that was a
very long talk I hope you really liked
that and the plan for an LP series is to
do like a lot smaller talk in the future
with like more basic information so if
you like this you can say it and you can
send us feedback and we continue with an
LLP series as well